I want to [ __ ] a priest  Catholic yes a good one yes looks good  in the uh yes I understand  do you really want to [ __ ] the priest or  do you want to [ __ ] God  can you [ __ ] God oh yes For Better or  For Worse how do you wish you were more  like your character it is for it is both  for better and for worse because I think  feedback says what she thinks whether  it's to the camera privately or in real  life she says what she really really  thinks in the moment and I think I'm  still learning how to do that writing  for me and writing these characters for  me is like how I do that so I write  women who don't give a [ __ ] because I'm  teaching myself how to be one and I feel  such a catharsis when I do turn to the  camera and just like say that [ __ ]  line  do I have a massive [ __ ] and then oh  it's just such an amazing feeling I'd  like to be a bit more like that